it's always a great time to teach your
kids about financial literacy but
especially in april rocky spoke to clark
county credit union to learn why
april is financial literacy month the
perfect time to start teaching your
children
about financial literacy so what does
that mean for you guys over at clark
county credit union
so financial literacy is really just a
fancy way of saying we have the know how
to make wise financial decisions
and that includes knowing about loans
how interest works
credit cards saving for retirement you
know things that our kids aren't really
worried about now
but we want to take it down a level and
teach them something they can understand
so getting them used to those
wise financial choices and why do you
think it's so important to start them
early because i mean i'm you know in my
30s and i'm still learning so
i wish that i learned early yes i know
well the thing is like
we don't have financial education
courses in school anymore only six
states require them
so we're kind of on our own with our
kids to teach them about our finances so
really it's up to the parents and the
caregivers to just make it fun
at a young age so it's not intimidating
i mean it can be something as simple as
going to the grocery store and getting
to spend a dollar you know and how do we
spend that dollar
so just starting really young talking
about it making it normal making it fun
and setting goals i think that you know
in the future we want to buy a house we
want to buy a car
our kids don't really care about that
yet right they want to buy like
a soccer ball or a toy so making it in
in terms they understand
wow that's good give them a little money
and budgeted a little bit exactly
exactly okay so what age should you
should you start teaching them ideally
yeah so i have four kids they're six
years old to
13 yes four kids four's the new eight i
think so anyway
um so four kids and i think you can
start as early as three years old
a three-year-old may not understand the
value of money but they can understand
that money
is exchanged for goods so when we go to
the store
you have to have the money to get the
thing that you want the toy or the candy
or whatever
when they're a little bit older maybe
you start to add the value of money
i think that honestly the pandemic has
been awesome for my kids because we do
so much online shopping
they see how much things cost and it's
been really eye-opening so they want to
put something into the cart
and have to teach them about taxes so
they think how much things cost is you
know 9.99 i'm like actually it's going
to be closer to 11
so teaching them that even just the
concept of taxes has been good this past
year
wow your kids are going to be sharp i
hope so
okay and does clark county credit union
have those tools in place to help
parents teach their kids
clark county credit union has some
amazing free tools for parents
i would suggest even before you let them
have an allowance like check out our
our website we have a tool called bonsai
and there's the bonsai junior
bonsai teen and then for us adults
there's an adult version so you can go
and learn all about
making wise choices so the kids get to
pretend they have a lemonade stand
and make real world decisions like hey i
have to buy lemons i have to buy sugar
how much does this stuff cost do i want
to shop at the expensive store or the
discount store
and it just makes them make like kind of
choose your own adventure making choices
and seeing the impact it's really fun
yeah where were you guys when i was
growing up i know right me too
no really great tools give clark county
credit union a call at 702-228-2228 or
visit
ccculv.org
they have a great special offer for the
entire family free financial
gains and tools for kids with bonsai
cccu's
free financial education website there's
more las vegas now in less than three
minutes